okay well good afternoon everybody we're
going to get started here on our
round table so uh thank you for
everybody for joining us
to today's small business roundtable
thank you for uh being part of this
virtual format
that we have set up for today i want to
thank my staff that have done a good job
getting this all organized
so we can have a good productive
conversation as you all know one of the
priorities i laid out
in my 2021 state of the state address
concern continued assistance
for our small businesses which account
for almost half
of the jobs that we have here in the
state of nevada
i'm glad to pull this group together as
one more step in the process
to provide support for our vibrant
diverse
small business community throughout the
pandemic
our small businesses have worked hard to
meet the unprecedented challenges
and i know it has not been easy for any
of you
owners and staff have stepped up in
unbelievable ways
adapting the changes this virus has
caused all of us and continue
to adapt any way possible it's not lost
on me that the mitigation measures we've
put in place
to help keep people safe and the small
businesses open have had a serious
impact on your ability to conduct
business
and trust me i am doing everything that
i can
to loosen these restrictions that were
put in place
despite what you might have heard i've
taken no pleasure
in making these decisions quite the
opposite
i'm eager as all nevadans to bring back
our economy bring back our lives
better and stronger than ever before but
i know that we do as we work towards
these goals small businesses
need help now they need immediate
assistance
that's why i was proud to partner with
treasurer zach conan
and go director michael brown to launch
a small business assistance program that
was
named pets which is providing ten
thousand dollar grants to small
businesses
so far we've put fifty million dollars
into this vital program
in my state of the state address i've
asked lawmakers
to add an additional 50 million dollars
more
bringing the total to a hundred million
dollars once approved
i know that for small businesses in our
state ten thousand dollars can result in
keeping staff employed
and paying the bills to keep doors open
but we know that's simply not enough
that's why i've also partnered
with lieutenant governor kate marshall
to work to create a small business
advocacy center
to be a one-stop location to help small
businesses take advantage of the
resources that exist
and help them cut through the red tape
the goal is to create a centralized
location for small businesses
to get the help and resources that they
all need
today i am particularly excited to hear
from all of you
our small business owners the people
that are on the ground
on how the state can continue to support
you as we move forward
before we open it up to the small
business owners i wanted to introduce
who we have here at the round table with
us
first lieutenant governor kate marshall
is here with me
we also have treasurer you go to
wavegate there you are okay
we also have treasurer zack conan and
goat director michael brown
is also with us i'm glad to welcome
trina giles from grits cafe
thank you again trina for joining me in
my state of the state address
we also have cassandra barcelona from
empowered cafe
located in the grant sawyer building
this cafe is a true favorite of my staff
and i when i am in southern nevada
jonathan and ashley bradley are joining
us from spoon to bowl
they run a frozen yogurt and ice cream
food truck
as well as walter glacinski klishinki
i'm probably butchering that i apologize
walter from smiling whole pizza
and i have heard so much good stuff
about you i can't tell you
uh thank you for joining us here today
thank you you bet finally cody highsmith
from villa dantes is here with us
cody focuses on a restaurant and
hospitality consulting business
i think we're nearly ready to move on to
the next step of the round table
which is hearing directly from our small
businesses
then we can hear from lieutenant
governor kate marshall on how the state
can help small businesses find resources
and treasure coin on pets grants updates
before we pull
to a close i think i've got some staff
members i see megan delaney up in the
upper corner there
uh to help us move through the next
section and my chief of staff michelle
white is on here too so if you can see
her she's waving there you go
okay go ahead megan thank you governor
and i think michelle actually is going
to lead us through the next part but
thank you governor
i'll be back towards the end okay sorry
there michelle i put bacon ahead of you
go ahead
that's okay i knew she was your favorite
and yeah
um thanks thanks governor thanks
everyone for joining
um i'm so familiar with so many of you
and trina very nice to see you it's been
so long and i
miss your food very much and look
forward to being back down south to eat
it
um but i really wanted to get everyone
together today as governor said
on this on this push and assistance for
small businesses again we know that they
have been so hard hit throughout the
pandemic
um and one of the things you know the
governor mentioned was this additional
50 million dollars for
um the small business assistance grants
and
this has to go to the legislature or
require legislative action
to award that additional 50 million
bringing the total to 100 million
we've received incredibly positive
feedback um from the legislators we've
spoken to and really feel positive about
it but
i think we want to kick it off by
hearing from you all on
other things you'd like us to pass on to
them as some of you have been
recipients of this of the grant funding
and
anything you'd like for us to tell them
as far as how this has been beneficial
or what you've been able to do with
these funds
as you've navigated being a business
owner in this pandemic and i think we
can start there
we're gonna hear from the small business
owners is that where you're going here
who wants to jump first go ahead trina
oh just make sure to unmute you gotta
unmute there you go
okay hello everyone my name is trina
giles i
am the owner of grits cafe thank you
governor
for inviting me to the round table um
and thank you for allowing me to be a
part of your state of state address
that was very um positive for my
business
this pandemic has been um trying but
we're getting through it
and for me the funding will go directly
to payroll
um we did receive our funding some of
the challenges
that i've faced most recently that i
would like to
talk about is when an employee
of a small business test positive
for covet the impact
is similar to that of your family member
because we
are small business and so um
i most just recently had that happen
and my entire staff is being tested
we're slated to reopen on thursday
our results will be back thursday we did
get tested at the cashman phil center
set up by umc and homeland security
in the state and so i definitely
appreciate that
um as well as fogging and sanitizing of
my restaurant
and so during that time we're losing
revenue
as well as some of my employees
are losing their pay on the days that
were normally open
we've been closed since monday and we're
slated to reopen like i said
on thursday and so that's something that
if we could talk to legislation about um
how can we assist small businesses who
have
an employee who tests positive and how
we can assist them in
expediting getting their businesses back
open
um maybe expedited testing and
resources to continue payroll which um
i'll be using my pet grant for that
so just something that just happened
most recently and as we know this
pandemic will probably
end up affecting a lot of families and
small businesses eventually
so this is my
opportunity to share with you my
experience and maybe we can
look a little bit further into the
effects that it may have on small
businesses from
a employee who tests positive
thank you trina this is megan delaney in
the governor's office i'm gonna
jump in and sort of try to help keep us
moving along i think we do have folks on
staff who are taking notes
um and so we'll be able to collect all
the information you're sharing um and
try to work through these things as we
move forward so
thank you so much for for sharing that
um and i think if we
we can go next to the folks from the
empowered cafe in the in the grant
sawyer building if they're
on the line and can can unmute
themselves hi guys how are you
how were you hi we're kristen cassandra
from empowered cafe
a husband and wife team so we can be
without our mass
just kidding guys um so you know we
wanted to say
i want to piggyback off of what grits
cafe said there was those were very
valid points and
we actually just experienced very
similar situation because
i actually got covet and we had to shut
down our cafe completely
because we run it and then we have two
employees
and we had to completely shut down
because we didn't want to for one
affect all the state employees but also
affect
our employees and that was really tough
because we've lost out of three weeks of
business
and you know it went through our entire
family and
i immediately went into isolation
luckily our workers did not get affected
nobody at the state building got it from
us
because we were able to quarantine so
quickly
but three weeks our product went bad
um our employees were without pay for
three weeks
you know and that was really hard we did
just get the pets grant which is going
to help with payroll but
it's hard to cover payroll when you're
not working you know and
when you you can't we couldn't afford to
keep them on and then we'd run out of
the pets grant and then we'd still be
stuck where we were before
yeah plus like trina said before it's a
small business we only have two
employees right now
we had three before you know but um if
anybody got sick and had to take a two
to three week leave
i don't know how to replace them you
know and then i don't know how they're
gonna survive and and
what something unique about us is we try
to employ people with disabilities
that's the whole goal of our cafe
is to employ people with special needs
and we train the blind business
operators on how to run
on their businesses and we had to put a
hold on all of that
and cut back on how many employees we
could hire with disabilities which is a
shame because that's you know passion of
ours
um i think when looking to um find out
how we could do better at anything
i think looking at a global view is very
helpful
because other countries are doing
a lot more where us is only doing a
fraction
of what other countries are doing for
their small businesses and i think if we
could look at
what other places are doing and take
that in consideration the
um the small business advocacy center is
great because i actually had that
written down
a website for resources for small
businesses so i'm so happy to hear
the governor say that that is awesome
that's definitely a foot forward
public promotion of small business which
i hear grits cafe that's awesome i'm so
happy for that and i know the governor
has posted on
his twitter about us before and that
really has helped us too but
right now with uh the state building
being closed to the public it's a little
hard for us to
but maybe promoting more maybe doing
like a a weekly or a monthly
promotion of a small business that's
near and dear to your heart i don't know
if you're already doing that i'm sorry
i do follow you but there's so many
tweets and stuff
it's hard to keep up right um i was
thinking to like maybe forgiveness for
utilities if
and rent if the if the place does have
to close down
because of covid affecting them even a
partial forgiveness or a partial
forgiveness something like that i don't
know it's just
just thoughts um maybe a state tax
relief for small businesses that have
less than a certain amount of employees
a temporary wage subsidy for for a few
months for those workers
that are working for small businesses
maybe that could help relieve
some of us i know canada is doing
something like that where they are
helping small businesses by providing
like 56 cents an
hour to that small business to give
directly to their employees and that way
it helps the small business intern
and just ideas that i have found from
other places
um i think you know the pets grant has
really helped us because it is
definitely going to help us play our
employees
and get back on track and actually buy
product now since we had to run out of
product
since our product went bad from being
closed for covid
you know the pets grant saved that it
did and if you guys can help more places
with the pets grant that is awesome it's
just great
and i think nevada is doing a really
good job to try to help its small
business
and i appreciate being part of this
roundtable
those are just a few of our thoughts
thank you
thank you and uh chief of staff white
did you want to say something before we
move on to the next businesses
sure um no i was just going to chime in
thank you for that input especially on
the
the positive cases within businesses
in our office as um as you all know
we've had
positive cases like many other offices
around the state in the country
in the world or businesses and
it is uh we are i think you know after
that that first time where
a lot of our staff had to go into
quarantine we all
you know really uh understood in a
personal level what it meant
um to have the luxury of being able to
work from home
um and that was a privilege for us to be
able to
to be able to do that not everyone
especially our small businesses have the
ability to do that and that's
uh inc so incredibly challenging um
and and you know a million thoughts are
going through my head as you all are
saying these things and governor i know
they're going through yours too
um and i'm really looking forward to
talking to director cage our kova
director after this about
um there's been a lot of rapid
development when it comes to testing
ways to deploy that testing um that can
be more targeted
and we've started to look into some of
those things but but hearing this from
both of you so far i know we have more
small businesses to get to
um i think it it's even further proof
and evidence of why
um you know this this evolution of
testing needs to
uh needs to continue in nevada as well
and make sure that we can provide that
more
targeted approach and so i just wanted
to chime in and say that this is
really good information for us to bring
back to our health teams too and and
kind of bridge
between the economic side and the health
side since everything is all
interconnected now
can i just ask one more question are i
don't know
in the vaccination um tears where small
business owners are i'm also an educator
so i know i'm going to be getting mine
soon but
we're in the tier our small business
owners and their employees
and i know you know we have the 70 plus
getting theirs and the
in the front of the line healthcare
workers but you know small businesses
are kind of like front of the line right
now too
so what are your thoughts with that and
where are they in the tiers because i'm
not sure
about that well we are doing everything
we can
totally understand the situation with
small businesses
obviously the teachers want to be at the
front of
first responders health care workers
essential workers and small businesses
obviously that all fits into the mix
we're trying to do a balance between our
most vulnerable population and our
businesses to try to impact the economy
as little as we possibly can and keep
you open so the more vaccines we get
and i can tell you michelle spends 26
hours a day
on the phone trying to get us more
vaccines uh she's calling everybody
that'll listen to her and some that
won't listen to her
uh just to try to get more vaccines it's
that important to all of us so
we will continue to be aware of that but
suggestions that you're making are good
and
i know kate marshall the lieutenant
governor is up there in the upper right
hand corner and uh
taking us all in and coming up with
ideas
along with michael brown and zach so
you've got all of our years so we
appreciate the good ideas that are
coming forward
and just let you know really quick
thanks um thanks
that's exactly right we're trying to get
those more vaccines he's saying i'm
calling but um
there is no one who's calling more than
the governor and i think washington dc
is very well aware of that
at the moment which is a good thing um
and as far as your vaccination question
goes um we can get more information on
small businesses
that essential worker tier that front
line worker tier i think we all hate the
word essential
very much so thinking of front line who
has public exposure
things like that the department of
public health and the immunization team
as they put that lane together
um obviously you mentioned educators are
closer to the top there is a bucket in
that lane for frontline commerce and
service industry
um that includes for food service and
hospitality
um and that includes restaurant workers
that includes
cocktail waitresses who work on the
strip or in a property in
in reno etc and throughout the state um
and
and the governor you know really
emphasized that as the team was looking
at that
um and we are one of the few states that
have explicitly called out those groups
now we hope that we get so many vaccines
at one point that prioritization
no longer has to exist and we don't have
to go by group
and everyone's getting vaccinated a much
bigger pool but
for now the governor really fought hard
to make sure that that was part of that
tiered system
thank you michelle and thank you gov and
the folks from empowered cafe
i think the next folks uh that we were
hoping to hear from are the uh jonathan
and ashley from
from spoonable and i think there's just
one of you um there right now so we'll
take your opinions
on your insight hi yeah thank you so
much for having us or having me
i'm ashley bradley i own spoonable uh we
are a food truck
that sells frozen yogurt ice cream and
sorbet uh in las vegas
um we were also a pet's grant recipient
and i can't stress enough
um how grateful we are for that grant
and how important it was for us in our
business
um honestly if we had not received the
grant we likely would not be operating
right now
um you know our business is a little bit
challenging because we are
a mobile business and there's also a
seasonality
as a part of our business as well so we
operate from
march through november and from march
through november we just have to work as
hard as we can
so that we have enough money to sustain
our fixed
costs throughout the winter and when we
scale back um
and so luckily with the pets grant we're
super excited that we will have the
opportunity to have another season
um next year um i think one thing that's
going to be
important for us and something to
consider is um
many mobile businesses like us um we
100 depend on events and we understand
that right now there aren't any events
because
it isn't safe to do so so we we totally
get that
um and one thing that we i guess want to
stress is things start to open
up we understand that it's not just
going to be this
flip of a switch and everything is just
going to be open back
up and everything is going to be back to
normal we understand that it's going to
be a progression
um so as we go through that progression
it's going to be super important that we
just continue
um to get more support and more
financial support
because i think sometimes what happens
is we feel a little bit of pressure
to open up and operate because we need
the money and sometimes it's not safe to
do that we understand
that we have to keep safety first um
always
and so uh you know i think you know one
thing to maybe consider
is sometimes you may need um some sort
of stipend or incentive to close your
business because it's not safe to
operate
but again you you know feel pressure to
operate because you need the money
it trickles down to the consumer as well
and people feel
pressure to you know support small
businesses and go to small businesses
because they don't want them to close
but sometimes it's not safe to do that
um and so again
for a business that is mobile and
we really depend on on events for our
success
we also operated at unlv so that was
huge for us as well too we just started
doing that
um and so we understand that we have to
do that safely
but we just asked you know as you guys
continue to work to help small
businesses
that you um think about ongoing support
and how what that will look like as
things begin to reopen
and maybe even consider some incentives
for uh businesses where it might not be
safe for them to open in any capacity at
this point and
again just continue support as we uh
get vaccinated we're all super excited
to get vaccinated but until
things you know 100 go back to normal
that continued support is going to be
really important
thank you ashley i think you raised a
lot of good points specifically about
your
your business and your type of
businesses that are definitely reliant
on events and
being mobile and moving around so we
really appreciate that insight
um i have walter from smiling with hope
pizza next on my list
and walter um are you able to unmute
yourself and provide some feedback as
well
yeah am i unmuted i can hear you my
first zoom
i never zoomed before we're glad to have
you
yeah thank you for having us um i
want to thank the governor first of all
i read about all the flack you're taking
i mean no matter what you do you're
gonna have people wanting to
hang in praise you you know and you're
hanging with it all in your staff
thank you so much it's very inspiring
i don't know how you do it i i'd quit
it's amazing thank you for doing the
public service and taking the heat
walter i'm gonna interrupt you you're
the inspiration you folks are the
inspiration that keep us going believe
me
day in and day out and i appreciate you
for that so thank you
okay yeah um i i have a
kind of uh i don't know maybe an
interesting take on all this stuff
i i started out as a school teacher a
special education teacher and i taught
in big school districts like austin
texas
uh where if i was sick i'd pop a few
numbers on the phone and there's a sub
uh if i need an operation i get a leave
of absence
this the system keeps rolling um
and i created award-winning bakeries and
pizzerias with special needs children
and uh that's what led us to do this
when i stopped teaching my wife and i
are both senior citizens
we work all hours i make every pizza
i make every dough i shop every day at
this the markets for
produce and we have a total of nine
employees
and they're all well eight of uh three
of them are special needs
because that's our mission to employ
people with special needs
three of them are special needs people
that historically would never have a job
due to their cognitive limitations um
but my background
and my wife's background she works
full-time too
so we're there 24 7 at our business
if i had my hips replaced a year and a
half ago both of them we had it closed
for three months before the virus
our employees are mainly college
students at unr wonderful students
but they live communally and they get
exposed to the virus
all the time my roommate was exposed to
someone
so they have to get tested so all of a
sudden our staff
which is so unlike being in a big system
where you have subs
you're short um it
it was getting so complicated that in
january first we decided to close our
business
until we get our vaccine a friend of
ours have died
several have had the virus they're
having lasting effects
you know you know i have to tell you
about that so
judy and i just feel that we needed to
close
so we're closed right now uh during the
pandemic we're doing great
financially uh we're the number one
rated pizzeria in the united states on
yelp we're kind of famous
and we have plenty of customers they
come from all over the world so we
didn't we sell out of dough every day
we were the other side of the pandemic
we were doing
i had to cut back but i see so many
businesses friends small restaurants
their employees are making ten dollars
an hour they're get by people
they come to work sick and don't say
anything because they have to eat
and you can't blame them for that so
it was just getting too scary for us so
we shut down we didn't take money
from the grant because we didn't need it
now we've been closed and we don't know
when we're going to get our vaccine
we keep applausing checking websites and
it's so confusing
we have a friend who works with us she's
actually 70 she ran
the downtown library and reno
and she loves pizza and she's from new
jersey like me so she works with us
part-time she's 71.
she just got her vaccine but she was on
the phone for 11 hours
pushing push and pushing pushing trying
to get in the queue
so we're really confused about when it
opens up
how there doesn't seem to be a lot of
clear cut and i understand because
everything's on the fly
you know you're playing on this like a
football game you're changing on the fly
so the more instruction we can get
as to when the vaccine for our employees
like we want to get our special needs
employees and all our
college student employees vaccine and us
before we go back to work because we're
just scared
we're going to die and most people can't
afford
to do what we're doing and that's the
sad part i go now as a customer to a
restaurant to support them
and i walk in now as a customer and i
see this food service people working
i'm going oh my gosh what are oh
it's just it's terrifying yeah and i
know you're doing all you can but if we
could get more
clear instruction
on when we're eligible how do we get on
the queue
who do we go to where do we go things
like that would really
help a lot from our perspective
thank you
thank you walter i see the governor it
looks like he's gonna weigh in a little
bit there so god but you want to walter
yeah thank you very much and to hear
what both you and the folks at uh
empire cafe are doing for helping our
most vulnerable i sincerely appreciate
that and grits
we are doing believe me and i understand
the
urgency and the desire to get vaccines
we are doing
everything humanly possible and then
some to get more vaccines into the state
and
i would like nothing better than to just
open the doors and open
mass vaccination sites and get needles
stuck in everybody's arm but
we're not quite there yet believe me
we're working on it
uh every minute of every hour every day
our federal delegation is working on it
uh i'm seeing that the government is
buying more vaccines now the
manufacturers are ramping up
we've got a few new vaccines on the
horizon hopefully that uh
will be uh approved and we'll go from
there but
we i hear you i'm listening and we're
going to do everything we can
yeah you know i i appreciate that um
like i said i know it's all
new times it's we don't we can't look
back
we can't look back and say oh that
happened 10 years ago so here's what we
do
yeah you're doing a great job but yeah
hopefully things with the new
administration now we get
we get things rolling and thank you for
everything you're doing and
thank you to every good luck to
everybody out there on the panel
i mean i like i said we're one of the
few that were making money
so i i just feel terrible i feel
terrible you didn't do nothing wrong
you know you yeah thank you we
appreciate you walter and i'll tell you
what
at some point when your vaccine
vaccinated we're going to drive to reno
and get pizza and bring it back to my
office so
you saved some of that pizza dough for a
late night called
with you anytime sir thank you thank you
goodbye thanks
thanks megan thanks governor thank you
walter i think governor knows that pizza
is my absolute
um favorite food so we will make good on
that promise
and um walter i know you said this is
your first zoom call so if you go back
to that little microphone i'm gonna mute
yourself again
perfect and then i think um that brings
us to the last business we have on our
panel which is um cody
hi smith so cody um if you want to
unmute yourself and provide a little bit
of information and some of your insight
we're so excited to hear it
great thank you so much for having me
and uh now i'm very hungry for pizza so
uh okay so we're veodantes and we do
hospitality consulting whether it's in
nightclubs lounges
restaurants you name it we pretty much
do it and we're kind of in a
unique kind of area because we solely
rely on
you know tourism to come and
demand you know drive demand for rest
new restaurants new lounges or whether
it's
consulting with the restaurants on how
to get you know additional
people from korea into the restaurant so
on and so forth so for us we've been
looking at ways to try and diversify our
reach and
take our knowledge that we've learned
here in the state of nevada
obviously i grew up here i went to unlv
for grad school undergrad
so it's um obviously vegas is near and
dear to my heart so
we like to take what we have learned and
try to apply it in other places but with
us
we've been doing my wife and i it's a
family business my wife and i we want to
build something great for
our almost two-year-old son so what
we've been doing is obviously working
from home but
for us what we've noticed talking with
other businesses and business owners is
there's
really kind of um there's no centralized
online resource where small businesses
can go to figure out how to
whether it's diversify their business
how to expand their business during the
pandemic
or even how to work from home um i know
a lot of my friends who run businesses
they have no idea how to onboard anybody
whether you know they they want to hire
people or potentially they can because
their industry is booming but they don't
know how to onboard anybody in order to
pass anywhere from home so there's a lot
of challenges that small businesses are
facing
obviously ones that don't have brick and
mortar facades
um so that you know when the governor
said about the centralized online forum
and the website i think that's going to
be a huge bonus they're going to get a
lot of hits
on that and for us what we're seeing
is you know companies need to evolve
like ours we're
constantly trying to evolve now and and
look for new potential clients new
potential industries to get into but i
think it kind of goes back to
the diversification of industries within
vegas
per se obviously nevada is doing great
with you know
the solar and industry and everything
coming in and all the data banks
but i still think it boils down to
bringing in additional
businesses whether it's the medical
field um you know pharmaceuticals
whatever it may be to help
drive the small businesses because if we
had a couple additional
you know sources of income we could
you know like the ice cream shop or the
pizza shop or whatever it may be
people will be still be shopping there
or buying pizza there because
the farmer's school industry's you know
basically still working
like normal um you know and so on and so
forth so i think
that's probably more of a global issue
for the state and i know the governor's
been pushing to get more industries in
and i think that
will help alleviate our requirement on
tourism so much where
you know i know obviously our business
is based on tourism so
i think um you know a centralized source
also on how to you know diversify would
be great
and obviously we want everybody to you
know shop local but also
i understand that if we just shop local
the people that are working at the
larger hotel chains
they won't have a job you know they are
locals as well so
for us it's just more of um just trying
to diversify
and and i think the the state's been
doing great with adding the grants and
having more and more money which is
fantastic
and i think that it's somewhat on us
as well to not just rely on the on the
state and the government but it's also
us to try and evolve we have the ability
to evolve obviously some brick and
mortar businesses they can't
they can't expand their reach apart from
like a five mile radius or whatever the
delivery radius is
so for us it's just about possibly
expanding and finding new opportunities
with
within this new crazy world that we live
in
so that's where uh that's my my take on
it and hopefully
that was worth the couple minutes there
so i apologize if i just rambled for a
bit
nope we wanted to hear what you had to
say that was very impressive it's
important and you made some good points
so thank you for that okay
thanks send it great thank you cody
thank you governor
um so those are the small businesses
that we were able to have join us today
um the next portion of this round table
we'll be hearing from
our very own lieutenant governor kate
marshall on some ways
the state can help small businesses find
resources i think we've started to hear
some
some great suggestions there so we'll
turn it over to the lieutenant governor
to
provide some some insights and some
thoughts there
thank you megan and thank you governor
first off for having me as part of this
roundtable
and for your leadership in recognizing
just how important our small businesses
are
to our economy here in nevada and
the many and varied needs that they have
i i also want to mention um speaker
fryerson
because he is also working with us on
this
bill uh to create a small business
center that the governor has
identified as a need and that you guys
have identified as a need
one of the things that i'm hearing from
you guys other than the fact that
uh you have grits and my my dad is very
specific
about how he likes his grits i
do i mean do you run into this where
people go into your restaurant i go
okay there's certain ways we rich right
okay so just
i just want to make sure we're like that
um but one of the things that i'm
hearing from you
and one of the things that we've seen in
the data is that the difference between
a small business being
able to keep on going during this time
or have to shut its doors can be whether
or not they can
access the kinds of programs that
federal and state and local governments
have to help our businesses get through
and so one of the reasons that the
governor is showing this leadership with
respect to small business center
is to make sure that there is a place of
contact
where my office can then say
all right these are your needs we're
going to connect you
to where we can meet those needs with
the kinds of programs the federal
government has the state government has
and local government has
so that access and making sure you have
access can be the difference between
your ability to make it through this
pandemic
or not but we also know that the
pandemic
in some ways this aid having these
grants and things
is masking the incredible damage
that is being done to our small
businesses because it's not just about
opening the door but it's about thriving
and for our economy to thrive we need
you to thrive
so in addition to this resource
center connecting you with those grants
we also need to make sure that going
forward
you can call and we have a back phone
you can call and you say hey i don't
know what's going on with my license
and we have a back phone and help you
navigate what's going on there
you can call and say uh you know
taxation just said that
i don't know what and we have a backbone
and we can help you work through that
right
so that's the second piece that the
resource center will do
the third piece is we cannot improve
what we don't measure
as you guys know in the business right
got to know what is going on before we
can make it better
so is to make sure that we identify the
concerns that we're hearing from small
businesses
and where they're saying that we need to
step up to the plate
in a better way and then provide that
information to our legislature
and to our governor so we can improve on
our systems
and so that we can continue to provide
you better and better service
because at the end of the day government
is about we
are serving you that's what we're about
and so our ability to create this center
to connect you to grants and programs
through the that are available because
of the coronavirus and the pandemic
to be a back phone for needs that you
have ongoing needs that you have because
i don't think any of you have a huge hr
department
i'm just guessing but i i think that's
right right
and then lastly to make sure that we
measure so we can improve
so that you guys can thrive so that we
can eat pizza
so that we can get grits i love frozen
yogurt
and so that we can go to the that
restaurant in the grand sawyer building
you guys are wonderful
and i i just i'm so appreciative thank
you for what you do
and with the governor's leadership we
are going to create this resource center
for you
thank you thank you lieutenant governor
that was a
great update and i know that all the
folks here are looking forward to
continue working on this um
governor did you want to weigh in i did
i just want to say thank you very much
lieutenant governor we're
counting on you to put this together and
provide your bath phone
so that they all have a place to call
and get through these problems but
to and kate understands we're going to
do a lot more listening than we are
talking
because we need to hear your your
situations
the problems you face in your potential
suggestions because you're closest to
the situation and
we're counting on you to help us provide
provide some of the answers so
thanks megan thank you governor and and
thank you lieutenant governor kate
marshall again
um at this time i think we're going to
hear potentially from both treasurer zac
conan
and the governor's office of economic
development executive director
michael brown for an update on the pets
program
and then we'll have time for a short
media q a before we pull to a close at
three
so i'm treasurer conan or director brown
thanks so much megan and uh governor
thanks so much for having us today
lieutenant governor it's always a
pleasure and i'm for one looking forward
to activating a light
on the top of the building so we can
signal you when there's a small business
problem
and you can sweep into action you know
that idea really came out of a bunch of
calls that director brown and i made
wanted to make sure that money was going
to small businesses like you and not to
fraud
so a lot of times we end up getting on
the phone and reaching out and
trying to make sure that there's a small
business on the other end of that
application
and a lot of those conversations went
something like oh that's great i really
need the money i'm going to be able to
use it to keep people employed
but while i got you can i help get a
little help on something else and i
think what we've realized through this
process is
there is a massive need for assistance
for small businesses and it's not just
monetary so i'm so glad
that that resource center will be up and
running uh so that people have someone
to call
you know with pets we received
applications for more than 13 000
businesses
representing a need of almost 150
million dollars
the program started small it started at
20 million now it's at 50 and with the
legislators
uh help will be getting up to 100
million dollars which will make it the
largest small business assistance
program
in the history of the state and you know
we've learned a lot along the way and i
think we've learned that from the
entrepreneurs that we're
talking to now uh you know you all have
had to pivot
10 different ways in the last couple of
months and you've
carried a lot of the load for the state
right we ask folks to stay home
and stay safe you're the ones actually
making sure that your employees can stay
safe and that they're making the right
decisions
uh when they don't feel well that your
customers can come in
and be safe right and i know that
sometimes that's really really difficult
i i come from the restaurant industry
i know what it's like when bob has a
tough night and can't come in and wash
dishes
that's a different thing when it's a
pandemic right that's not just a
a couple of hours of difficulty that can
be a couple of weeks and and we hear you
uh and we're glad we're able to provide
this bit of support and i i really
appreciate all the suggestions about
other types of support because
we're always trying to figure out the
best way
to help out but oftentimes it's you all
who know the best way to help out so i'm
hopeful this is the beginning
of a number of conversations and we've
had plenty of conversations offline and
i'm deeply
looking forward to bringing uh my
three-year-olds
and my seven-year-old out to get frozen
yogurt uh they certainly ate a bunch of
snow this morning uh but
you know later on down the road i think
there's an opportunity for flavoring
um but we've gotten out about 42 million
dollars with the 50 million dollars with
pets grant we'll be out
uh the rest of the 50 million in the
next couple of weeks
and hopefully the legislature uh is able
to pass that bill
and prioritizes putting money back into
nevadans pockets as much as possible
we're going to keep fighting to get you
the funds that you all need
as long as you keep telling us what we
can do better it is all very much
appreciated
thank you so much yeah let me just say
walter the statement you made about
trying to help the get by people
that just hit me really really right in
the heart i mean that's those are the
folks
we're ultimately trying to help and uh
helping small businesses get through
this
helps those folks too and you know we
appreciate the support we also got from
the latin chamber
the las vegas chamber the reno chamber
in government communicating with small
business was its own challenge
and without those chambers you know they
they made it all possible
and then cody your comment about
diversification that is what we have to
do
and when you see initiatives like what
the governor has for the medical school
and for the engineering school at unlv
those are the little legos that help
build the foundation
for something bigger so for us to bring
manufacturing to the state to bring
uh advanced healthcare to the state
those two those two projects are
critically important they're
they're they are the foundation and i'm
the guy who's been listening and taking
notes and i appreciate all of this
insight
thank you very much thank you treasurer
conan and director brown before we take
a couple questions from the press who
joined us i wanted to provide one last
opportunity for our
business owners who are on the zoom with
us today if there's anything
that the governor or the lieutenant
governor or the treasurer or director
brown have said that that you would like
to
pipe in with right now so we can get it
on the record and so director brown can
take notes on it
i think we can can do that before we
move into a quick q a
with our members of the press
okay well i'm not seeing anyone move to
unmute so that's great and so
i will turn it over quickly to members
of the press were on the call
they have many of them have been on a
zoom with me before so if you would not
mind using the raised hand feature
and then i'll call on you and you can
ask your question so we'll give it a
second okay great i see bob conrad from
this is reno with his hand raised first
so bob you can go ahead and
ask your question and april will go to
you next
i just want to say thank you we are a
recipient of the pets grant
it's very helpful to us we are a small
business operated on a shoestring budget
and
it's been very helpful to us so thank
you for holding this forum
well thanks bob i was expecting a
question but i think that's uh even
nicer than a question
so i think maybe april will have um a
question for some of those on the panel
so april if you want to go ahead and
then if there's anyone else who wants to
raise their hand
we'll put you in the queue next yeah uh
you know it was mentioned that
almost uh 150 million dollars was
requested during that initial
application
you've given out 51 million assuming the
legislature passes
an additional 50 million that still only
covers
two-thirds of those initial applications
um so are there any plans to
push this pets program uh beyond
uh what you're currently asking for in
from the legislature
or what else needs to be done i guess
beyond this to help small businesses
because the need is overwhelming
obviously
well abram as i think you know we're
facing a difficult budget situation this
time around uh we're doing everything we
can we found 50 million dollars to put
into this program and
and i'm thrilled that we're able to find
50 million dollars i'm
i'm the type to look at the glasses it's
two-thirds full now not a third empty
uh you know we've managed to help
two-thirds of the businesses hopefully
with this being approved through the
legislature i'm proud of that i'm
excited for those businesses and
we'll have to wait and see what comes
from the federal government in terms of
any potential funds for uh helping our
budgets across the country but for right
now we're going to be at 100 million
dollars
and governor if i may certainly
one of the things we've also been doing
april is we're directing people to other
sources of funds
so the paycheck protection program which
is helpful for some of the businesses
uh that will also apply for pets is open
there's also been grants at different uh
cities and county levels and so we're
working to push people in those
directions while we continue to ask the
federal government
for the support we very much need thank
you for that question april and thank
you governor and treasurer for providing
those really helpful answers hopefully
if there are other businesses watching
who
may need that assistance they can reach
out to the treasurer's office
for some of that so i don't see any
other hands raised from members of the
media who are on the call
there we go stamps from the ap of course
go ahead sam
hi everyone thank you so much for taking
the time today
i wish i had a question for the business
owners instead of
a budget question but alas um
my question is does the 50 million come
from the general fund or is the hope
that the legislature passes it
using federal relief dollars either yet
to be passed or left over from the cares
act
i can jump in here go if you want
thanks michelle yeah go ahead michelle
great thanks sam that's a great question
um uh i and i was
fighting my tongue to jump in because um
gov is is not giving himself as much
credit there
he didn't uh the 50 million dollars is
not just found he worked really hard
um with the coronavirus relief funds
money that we had
in 2020 to strategically utilize those
funds
um you know reminding everyone that we
had that original 12
30 deadline for expending all of them
that ultimately got extended on the 27th
three days before um but the governor
uh worked hard to make sure there was a
plan for uh
for the ability to use some of those
funds into 2021 in case at that deadline
um did occur at the at the end of 2020
and so
um because of that strategy and because
of really being resourceful and
thoughtful about
how we budget with that sierra money um
there was that carryover
and that carryover was approved by the
by the legislature
um at an ifc meeting um and last year
and now goes into the general fund and
so uh it will have to be
uh reappropriated back to fiscal year
2021 by the legislature in this upcoming
session
and then can go out as an appropriation
to the pets program
thank you michelle and thanks sam for
the question um and then
i know that alexander from univision is
having trouble with his microphone so i
think this is a question for you
treasurer
um he would like to know so he can tell
folks
where they can find out more information
um about some of the
other services and grant programs and
federal funds that are being
offered i i believe you can handle that
question treasurer
thanks so much megan um i'm sure my
staff will appreciate this the easiest
way is probably just to reach out to us
uh and email us at ask nevada
treasurer.gov we can point you in the
right direction
but also i'd really encourage folks to
reach out to their local chambers
chambers like the latin chamber of
commerce have been doing really yeoman's
work getting the word out
and making sure that people can apply
for things
another great resource is your bank if
you have a banking relationship
groups like the nevada bankers
association have been doing a lot to try
and make sure that those funds get to
where they need to go
and that businesses are able to apply uh
but i think the best advice i can give
to anyone is if you need help
reach out because we can always send you
to the right department but i think the
most important thing is to raise your
hand and say you need help
we're here to help but thank you
treasurer and at this time i think we'll
take some closing remarks from
the governor and then we'll pull to a
close for today so
before i kick it to the governor i would
like to thank everyone for being here
this is
i think the one of the first steps in
the in the process here and so as much
as we can continue to
have these conversations and as the
governor said do more listening than
talking
i say is probably the person who has
talked the most on this roundtable
will continue to do so so thank you for
being here and governor if you have any
closing thoughts before we pull to
uh to a conclusion here well i want to
thank each and every one of you for
taking the time to join us and of course
my staff and uh
lieutenant governor and treasurer and
michael brown and everybody but
i learned a lot listening to you what
you had to say and there's some areas
that we can improve that we can do
better
and one of the things you talked about
was publicity and i'm going to get it
together with megan and
there's got to be a way and i'm going to
ask this of the media i know sometimes
you find a way to
to write articles and some of them are
supportive and some not so much
maybe write a little article however
feature where you feature
one or two businesses a day a small
business and if the
current does it and the indie does it
and the rgj and the
rj and every the tv stations do it we
can get the word out there i mean we've
heard some great stories i mean walter
and
you know grits and i mean you guys are
incredible and power cafe what you've
done
these are great stories and we got to
get out to the public and say
hey look if you're going to go buy a
coffee you don't have to go to starbucks
you can go to a local place and buy the
coffee
you don't have to go to pizza hut you
can go to local pizza parlor
we should tell these stories because
they're wonderful stories that show what
true events are the true resiliency that
you have
and we can do a better job amplifying
that and i guarantee you my office will
do it megan's
when megan gets an idea she's pretty
determined about it she can tweet it out
there we can have carson the tortoise
put it on his twitter or something
just get attention drawn to the fact the
great job that you're doing so
thank you for doing that and we're going
to continue to work with you and
lieutenant governor you've got a big job
ahead of you but i'm confident that you
can do it get this all done so thank you
all for joining us have a great day stay
safe everybody stay healthy